hollywood
was das feuer
murats ernsthaft so herzlich willkommen
zum murat und noch etwas ganz ganz ganz
ganz geniales und zwar ich mache was
ganz einfaches ich mache immer die
einfachen rezepte und zwar mache ich
heute was in unserem toaster diesen
toaster habe ich jetzt ungefähr schon
seit sieben jahren acht jahre
zehn jahre schon seit zehn jahren haben
wir diesen toaster und 11 jahre und wir
benutzen denn wirklich schon sehr lange
also seit elf jahren und auch fast
täglich und eigentlich ist also schrott
aber keine ahnung wie willst du trotzdem
so und was mache ich heute und zwar wir
machen heute ein big mac dos santos der
schmeckt wie ein big mac und damit ihr
auch damit ist auch jeder nachmachen
kann test mir normalerweise alle rezepte
an schimpansen aus und heute nachgedacht
und heute haben wir gedacht ich meine
schimpansen das kochen beizubringen
das kann ja jeder deswegen habe ich euch
nicht nur etwas trocken deswegen habe
ich jetzt wieder eingeladen
juni herzlich willkommen juni ihr kennt
ihn jeder kennt ihn
und obwohl auf mein zimmer auf jeden
fall heute noch was ganz besonderes uns
war wir werden diese diesen big mac aus
dass jan penny drin aus hackfleisch
wir werden aber was anderes machen und
zwar werden keine hackfleisch machen wir
werden dieses gleich werden wir in
kleine stücke schneiden
genau ganz ganz fein warum machen wir
das gericht nicht ganz folgen ja schon
etwas gröber ja etwas gröber warum
machen wir das noch mal kein grund
drucken will genau das nicht ist trocken
wird und vielleicht können wir es auch
ein bisschen medien machen hierzu in
unserem fleisch letztlich ein bio
fleisch von einer glücklichen co wir
haben wir uns für den nacken entschieden
weil der nacken hat ungefähr 25 prozent
fettanteil es ist anders weil ihr bei
diesen 35 es wäre dann wenn du jetzt
erst dann wärst du jetzt der bauch mit
welt anteil von 35 prozent
80 ich wäre wahrscheinlich tafelspitz
ja auf jeden fall vom nacken oder auch
ist man indes auch kam
oder man nimmt es auch als richtig
ja ich weiß wie sehr interessiert
sondern achtet nicht drauf holt euch
einfach ein kilo fleisch mit mindestens
fettanteil von 25 prozent ist und doch
habe so ein richtig hartes abgemessen
dem die idee vergiss es mir auf jeden
fall haben wir hier zwei osmanische
schlacht messer darf ich gern in die
hand geben jetzt werden wir dieses
fleisch ganz bescheiden ja ganz dünne
scheiben schneiden
so machen das so und jetzt machen so
kleine kätzchen richtig gut mal so sieht
es ungefähr aus joshua printz er das ist
bisschen sich so schneide ich es und
dann einfach nur drauf funktioniert
nicht doch doch das funktioniert man
muss es nur ein bisschen hacken in der
türkei nennt man das eventuell auch
special genau wir sind sich kusch
patienten die türkei muss ich weiß nein
muss ja nicht weil er ja wirklich weil
er kein englisch kann so ich habe ein
bisschen angst streichen ist es mir dann
haben wenn ihr ein holzbrett habt es
rutscht man schreit auf diese marmor
fläche nimmt ihr nas ist hoch danke
heidi man nimmt ihr nasses tuch ist hier
runter dann
das auch noch auch nicht mehr so
wenig umher so muss nach hause hat er
sich ganz einfache technik ich habe das
damals auch schon bei einem kochkurs 72
montreal gemacht damals war in mit
amerikanischen rock mannschaft dort und
habe diesen kuss gegeben
dann ist das einfach so und das klingt
ja wow was gesehen
ich bin so froh dass ich kenne wie eine
anatolische wald sind
[Musik]
wenn jetzt mal hier das fleisch hier
seht ist so richtig so könig also was
ganz ganz anderes konsistenz ist ganz
anders und konsistenz macht meinem
geschmack extrem viel aus konsistenz die
temperatur alles sind solche sachen die
eure neuro moleküle im mund genau und
richtig cool also ich würde mir immer so
pennies zu machen wirklich nicht so
richtig coolen geschnittene fleisch also
nicht gewollt und bistum jetzt die
reihen weit bestürzt und fertiggerichte
aus kurz darauf in mein auto zusammen
ich freue mich
ok so jetzt waren alles zusammen perfekt
also der größte teil ist jetzt fertig
und jetzt gehen wir dann zum nächsten
teil was man als nächstes weiß es genau
jetzt haben wir es geschnitten und juni
zwei coole hat spaß gemacht ganz
geschnitten ja wie man es halt sie wirst
du eigentlich besser wird es auch privat
zu hause wie du kannst jetzt couleur ja
kann ich das nicht nennen
auf jeden fall machen wir jetzt die
panels und zwar werden wir die pace in
einem penny forma formen
ok dazu nehmen wir diesen berlin vor mal
hier und zwar erst richtig gut der ist
aus keramik und zwar es aus keramik weil
ja der ist aus keramik weil dann ist das
schwer
genau aus dem grund hat eigentlich noch
das für diesen penny form annehmen und
man kann andere aber alles klar
also wir nehmen diesen coolen penny
format mit ich ich würde euch in keramik
empfehlen der ist richtig schön schwer
und ich hier oben steht auch drauf kommt
mal kurz her
ihr spruch dass man jetzt könnt ihr
sehen zb der classic hat in classic katy
perry hat 120 gramm ein kingsize hat 180
gramm
und wie gesagt datum und ist um uns
machen und wir tun es jetzt abwägen und
zwar nehmen wir hier
und zwar wie gewohnt lässig bürger oder
120 oder 180 gegen sagen sollte 180 hier
wollen ja ja wir haben ein kilo und
frauen
das heißt wir haben ein kilo fleisch und
geht er also kriegen wir vier penis auf
jeden fall raus oder bringt 5 180 900
oder
ja ich denke wir kriegen kannst du mit
aufgepasst
warum nur schlau geheiratet sondern das
ist jetzt immer hier und jetzt machen
wir nämlich tara und zwar so jetzt hab
ich gemacht und wie man bis 85 richtig
wenn wir eine 100
jetzt 181 so jetzt kann ich jetzt mal
statt
so weist noch was wichtig ist - und du
hättest früher einspringen sollen
ich stellte nun darf ich den ball ja ja
ja ich weiß nich gemeinde ich mich
gemeint ist erst mit brennsprit
einspringen müsste ich machen könnte
machen ist etwas wie intelligente lösung
okay in die vorderste förmigen jetzt
arbeitet man jetzt einmal diesen paper
jetzt hier und jetzt kannst du schon ein
bisschen druck ungefähr er misst
ungefähr 5 bar druck ausüben
das sind 45 baht rogosin
und dann haben wir da folgendes und dann
machen wird ist auf dieses aloe blacc
dieses alu blech ist genial warum weil
es ganz genau um den kühlschrank und ins
kühlfach reinpasst so machen wir das
hier drüber juni und das fest hat den
peggy drauflegen stürzen genau
doch so h also ein riesen penny gemacht
das ist ein ort ist immer genial
abhängig ob das mein ja immer für diese
kleinen ein klassik nein hinter durch
ein kinder verdienen sein dann geht man
ja das brauchst du noch mal oder
gesprüht ist dennoch fertig ja genau so
genau
foto 80 kommt ja
[Musik]
perfekt sei
dort hätte im klein-klein das ich mich
verarscht einen kleinen trocken retter
gesehen
[Musik]
beim penny form bislang vielleicht
manche von euch zu hause da gibt es
einen ganz ganz coolen typen man ganz
großen anfängerfehler machen kann
viele von euch zum beispiel sowie der
grünen die nehmen zum beispiel ist die
firma und diesen penny von swiss life so
einzeln rein sagt genau weiß man wie es
falsch aussieht wenn es so wenn es
ungefähr der gleiche machen würde so
groß wie dargestellt sagte kurz also
schon jetzt mit den folgen klar die
machen das fleisch hier ein auch wenn es
ist nach fleisch wäre
und dann drücken sie erst mal fest dann
nehmen sie den penny forma und drücken
drauf so ungefähr 5 bar und jetzt kommt
der fehler sehe das stop jetzt bricht
der partie auseinander
bevor jetzt ein cooler typ die mission
wissen normalerweise bin ich ein
performer habt könnt ihr es vielleicht
erst in die hand geredet es zusammen
dann ist es richtig eine homogene masse
wird zusammen riesigen schneeball um ihr
das gemacht habt dann schön pettyfer
drauf zack ungefähr 5 bar von reibung
und jetzt könnte das drauf machen es
perfekt und jetzt hält zusammen
keine angst haben wenn die penny es am
anfang etwas größer sind so peggy zieht
sich nachher wieder gebraten mit
ungefähr zu 33 grad zusammen ich habe
erst mal ausgerechnet jack early formen
3sat 3sat 3 303 satz genau geprüft ja
auf jeden fall
jetzt aber liegen cola anderer tipp
jetzt man auch viele viele diesen fehler
nehmen die paddys und tun sie direkt auf
dem grill riesengroßer fehler und zwar
cool ist wenn es kurz ins gefrierfach
reintun die pace richtig fest werden und
dann erst auf dem grill tun wir dann
fallen sie nicht auseinander und so auch
in den gefrierschrank gibt's alles
ungefähr eine halbe stunde drin lassen
20 mit einer halben stunde und außen die
forscher heraus holen und dann geht es
auf dem grill
die pace in den kühlschrank und dem eis
stand tschuldigung und sagen die pace da
drin sind machen wir schon mal die soße
und die gewürze und die bühne macht
diese weise einfach einfacher ist und
ich mache die gewürze so die soße von
einem big mac oder von unserem richtig
coolen mcdonald's burger ist einfach so
wir haben hier mayonnaise
man kann haben wir hier ein esslöffel
tomatenmark eine intel mit tomatenmark
eine prise salz zwei grüppchen
dann haben wir hier eine glückliche
zwiebelmarkt wird schon heiser ist eine
chance und konnten somit konnten neue
kombi aus frauen heute kommen bloß einer
komplett von jungen auch egal
auf jeden fall auch das ist es und zwar
an esslöffel essig kommt auch ein
die genauen zutaten findet auf dem blog
oder auf unsere app ja genau auf unserer
app wenn es heißt guck mal rein auf der
app richtig cool ist kostenlos im grunde
lagen also keine produktplatzierung
seien über diese kosten müssen ok
während danny könig ist alles zusammen
mix genau die zwiebeln und zwar ein
esslöffel gehackte zwiebeln fein
gehackte zwiebel fein gehabt kommen da
auch ein
genau dann ist hier die sowieso fällig
also alles ganz easy die sachen hat die
meistens zu hause so also während wie
die jetzt hier seine soße macht mache
ich was ganz spezielles möchte ich
selber machen weil das ist wirklich was
ganz ganz schwieriges und zwar habe ich
hier folgende zutaten für die für die
gewürzmischung und zwar habe ich hier
mehr salz - vielleicht kennt auf
englisch heißt es morgens und dann habe
ich hier noch treffer und zwar wirklich
ungemein ganz wichtig nicht gemalt für
das cover körner weil da sind die
aromastoffe noch drin dass da findet die
zeile aufbrechen und dann kommen wir
wo man besser zur geltung durch die
ätherischen öle genau durch das genau
dann habe ich hier selbst kann
selbst kenner können jede kritik haben
dann unbedingt unter den geschmack noch
ein bisschen note zu geben mache ich
noch braun superreichen ist auch eine
coole geschichte vielleicht habe ich das
übrig vielleicht habt ihr problem mit
alkohol und macht euch irgendwelche
storys dann hat er auch nur noch zu
berichten wo genau drei bringen so dann
folgendes dann haben wir noch ihr
chiliflocken so das ging jetzt alles
zusammen in den mörser und es ist ganz
wichtig bei einem mörser die richtige
handbewegung und zwar so ach ja ich
wollte testen irgendwann gut so drehen
okay jetzt mache ist unschön mit dem
moerser zerkleinern und es gibt eine
richtig coole gewürzmischung schön mit 5
bar druck das richtig wahnsinn war das
so ich kann es ja ich sagen das macht
mich richtig aggressiv euro
meinst du meinst ich hätte vor elf
jahren wo wir uns damals kennengelernt
haben erste mal gedacht dass wir sonst
so kochte tores zusammen
ich habe
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wie alt werden eigentlich wombats so
ganz ganz klar beim moerser nicht einen
fehler nicht machen
joschka kürzlich zeigen das ist ein ganz
typischer anfängerfehler weg ist bin ich
zum beispiel machen würde die wirklich
so machen wahrscheinlich entdeckt die
sich kein moerser die moerser richtige
schloss schläge so ernst oder warum das
nicht weil du sonst die zellen nicht
zerstören den hirschen nicht austreten
können ja immer die steine können wenn
die autofahrer aufgehäuft
komm mach den kopf tun da ich mache
weiter an doch noch nicht passiert ist
das haus erhält zerrbild augenlicht
verloren hier augenlider los okay jetzt
gehabt eine schutzgemeinschaft
und wie gesagt die müssen wir einfach
dass ich wieder los hatte ich hatte
schöne licht und 20 minten schlaganfall
ja ja nein doch dass man eine kleine
also in der zwischenzeit habe ich
schnell es geht viel zu langsam wird's
zeit sagt du musst abi sowieso ein
türkischer kuba sieht die krise ganz
klein sein
ihr habt deswegen tue ich sage nochmal
also ich krieg tränen der augen entweder
jetzt von der zwiebel das von deinem
axel max nacht mit für ein bleibt
rentner
ok wenigstens muss klar im freien
sonst hast du doch brocken des
russischen minuten rezept und zielen
machen und die conti- chance und zwar
keine chance dessen wirken die deren
ursprung aus frankreich wo sie zuletzt
gelesen kommt mit aus mexiko dann nehme
ich hier den dem teelöffel mit
tomatenmark
der ist übrigens dreifach konzentriert
du bist nicht nur einfach konzentriert
so dann nämlich eine prise salz 1
esslöffel essig kann das sein
das ist ab lässt ich guck mal kennst du
das so als hätten sie nur noch rein
drückt und er hat es aus hessen bayern
und apfelessig ist ja bekannt dafür
einen apfelwein und wir brauchen apple
wollen äppelwoi und bierbauch des
vereinshauses zusammen und ist immer ein
löffel und zwar gar nichts von den
nachweis ihrer geistigen schmutz machen
zur raub zeigt wohl dass im löwen in dem
es wenig ingenieure wird so machen wir
da hinten der messe ich aber nichts mehr
gefunden
also ist es doch gar nicht wie machen
sie probieren zwar mit dem löffel ja
richtig cool
das ding ist jetzt werden auch die farbe
hin bekommen wollt wie so ein big mac
wieso sind da könnte ein bisschen
kurkuma dass soeben ein kleines das wäre
dann die farbe und wieder die
zeitstruktur und auch wieder dies diesen
symbiotischen dieses symbiotische
geschmacksmuster tiefen ja auf jeden
fall wieder hat die züge geschnitten so
was ich jetzt machen werde ich habe hier
die soße
ich habe hier den genialen joe kaeser
ich hab hier die coole gewürzmischung
hier habe ich die zwiebeln
da ist juni und hier ist ostern ist ein
intelligenter als du weißt ja auf jeden
fall habe ich hier auch die er trat
schon an gemacht jetzt holt die teddys
aus dem kühlschrank gefrierfach
jetzt geht der wenigen die ich gehe
jetzt in den salat in den wald neben dem
rathaus eingang ins hotel schicken uns
unsere seite ziehen und die tomaten
wir kennen uns aus die wir noch nicht
waren jahrelang du nur du ja und beginn
ist
[Musik]
sorgt für die jetzt zum beispiel im
salat und zwar im eigenen hochbeet und
zwar was ich ihr salat weil es sich ja
alles grün
du bist doch dürfen sich keinen salat
wiese aber irgendwie ist keine ahnung
was ich weiß mein gott
ihr wisst ihr was salat nicht mal das
wir haben ein trick was ich das hatte
ich ein paar probleme hat ist das war
sauer anfang will man das nicht muss
klar übertreffen wird das rad also wo
wir mal lieber tot
aber wo gibt's denn so kopfsalat noch
ich habe meine frau und sagt dass du zu
blöd da rauszugehen den salat im
hochbeet findest du im gehirn das
hochbeet theorie ja das habe ich aber
nur zur show gemacht
das ist für mich alles nur grünen hier
ja ja ja ich hole jetzt meine frau
ich wollte nur sagen er weiß sie was
salat tomaten und herausgefunden da hat
auch geholt jetzt was ich dir salat
salat
ich habe doch gesagt du ich bin schon
gesagt ich hab doch gesagt niveau das
wusste auch schnittlauch dass sich
sauerampfer habe ich recht gehabt ernst
genau siehst du gar nicht gehen gar
nicht und es sah aus wie distel finde
ich jetzt lud am ramus nett sein aber
ich war jetzt so was wenn ich die auf
die nato box dann fühlst du auch aus wie
blut so aber wenn ich da eine soße
draufmachen schmeckt gut
der verlag hat man seinen glauben auf
danach haben schon zur ersten chance das
geschah erst schoss er sieht aus wie die
distel richtig schön
weißt du dass da die kriegen draufpacken
nein ja alles schwachsinn so achtet in
stabio alles bio basierten ist
eigentlich das schmeckt ja furchtbar
wenn man es geht mal so platter das auch
haben folgen ich musste auch gail das
basilikum auch solche dinger triebe
hatte das drama und country pop ach das
nächste jahr was man nicht mehr einen
ganzen werden pflanzen tatsächlich guck
mal hier sind mit pflanzen für das
nächste jahr
das wären nächsten an tieren ein nach
einem ganzen bus zurück langsam abgebaut
haben die familie so war das bei ihnen
da hilft haben das ist ja gut aus
mangold mit also ich fand mangold fand
ich richtig cool aber ich fand mangold
panini cool ich sag dir sind mangold
wird es auch mehr mangold essen
murat was für wichtige figur von
körperscannern nicht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
jetzt die pellis knie und ist richtig
cool geformt und jetzt ja auch schon
kommen das musst du mir mal anschauen
seht ihr mal diese pellis richtig cool
also keine hackfleisch richtig schön
geschnitten und es war auch folgendes
ich habe hier so eine grillplatte
bischen reis gemacht richtig cool und
dadurch die pellis jetzt drauflegen und
antraten
ich habe ein bisschen backt entsprechend
drauf gemacht so ich habe jetzt müssen
ich habe das ein bisschen back fence
sprechen entsprechend ganz normales raps
kokosöl also nichts besonderes so und
hier die pellis richtig schön knusprig
anbraten lassen ich möchte noch ein
bisschen medien haben aber schön
knusprig weil wenn sie nicht kurz trixi
dann zerfallen sie nachher also wenn es
richtig dunkel geworden sind umdrehen so
in der zwischenzeit genau dann geschenk
natürlich ein bisschen oben bisschen
würze jeder gewürzmischung weise gemacht
haben und lecker so und jetzt hier
sie ist es das thema partie ist ja auch
gefallen naja wurde ja also nicht
aufgefallen auf jeden fall hier hast du
die pen ist richtig schön anbraten
in der zwischenzeit machen wir den salat
und zwar rasch genau mit nur in seiner
raschen machen sie keine platzierung
machen und zwar haben wir hier die 7204
speedway co
und so habe ich mich ein bisschen wasser
eingefüllt so empfindet es da haben wir
hier unseren kunden salat geist auch ein
bisschen rucola drin den im garten
gepflückt haben
natürlich ist einfach rein und jetzt du
bist du hier drauf sollte hier einfach
ziehen
das ist es sagt sagt sagt du hast ja
salat eingeklemmt hastig haben sogar zu
blöd um eine isolation mehr zu benutzen
welchering sowieso blöd wenn wir nicht
mal eine salatschleuder berlin kann
nein es war ein kleiner fauxpas des
roten gruppe
und zwar habe ich das drehkreuz
vergessen
deswegen hat sich funktioniert so
zusammen es tricks drin
dadurch war ganz kurz siehst du das
gekommen sind so ein wissens im wasser
trinkt sie ist es perfekt und es reicht
vollkommen aus dass du alles kannte ja
wahnsinn ja so ist das alles schon
sauber da haben wir die bremse drin ist
muss es ja machen
das ist wasser raus also okay
nein so geriet fertigung unserer ich
mache das fleisch
[Musik]
genau jetzt kommen wird's im super-g du
bist sehr sehr achtsam aufmerksam
aufmerksam bis dahin hat der öffentlich
über seinen mann kommst du vorhast wärst
du meinen europe die weichere werden
dann brauchst du auch jetzt habe das
gemacht ist cool war wenn ihm alles
video davor war gesehen habt ihr's
hätten uns den post brot gemacht ein
selbstgemachtes toastbrot hier richtig
cool jetzt noch mal hier mal das
toastbrot ist ungleich posten toastbrot
als nächstes ging was kommt die
geschichte so so sehr okay wir haben
genau das schön draußen dann können wir
verbrauchen so sagt es wird richtig
lecker selbstgemachtes toastbrot jetzt
war nur kurz ab das dauert noch wird
aber gleich so weit sein so die tomaten
sind so geschnitten dass habe ich
gesehen die so schnell war ja mit diesen
aus den daten die tomaten geld bei uns
aus den daten das hat nur roboter kann
der kunde auch sollen wir haben keine
fixe hinten jetzt nehmen wir diesen
diesen penn state partie eigentlich so
zu sagen und machen dann riecht nicht
schön hier drauf sind genial aus was wir
jetzt noch machen ist allerdings
vergessen dass andere auch noch mehr wo
ich glaube dass ich mit den bürger so zu
machen nicht als hackfleisch ich ja fast
noch genialer
hammer hat mir einen burger kette auf
man so will übernimmt wollte ich so sich
daheim und heute morgen habe ich extra
noch den globus noch ein ding geholt
dann richtig coolen block mit cheddar
käse und den schneide ich jetzt noch
zusammen keller käse gehört auch ein
richtig coolen bürger werk schillers
richtig gut 40 genießt du es mir
eingefallen jetzt tust du noch die
zwiebeln drauf und die tomaten
so jetzt haben sie sich viel und tomaten
drauf ist aber kein platz mehr für
salate mit ihrem 8 parierte den teddy
runter und macht ihr salat mir dass du
sein muss sich auch sie kann sich aus
dem gegner mögen ja richtig cool und
jetzt noch folgendes noch ein bisschen
salat drauf komisch sich um dich herum
gelaufen bindung nicht völlig aus der
puste
die haben wir haben ja ein paar rucola
haben wir hier noch ein bisschen mangold
okay wisst ihr was ich weiß dass
rezepten nummer 1 pick pack burger sie
haben den big mac gar nichts mehr zu tun
aber es egal wer es trotzdem dann ist
sein blick geht okay man jetzt weg ist
was für brad pitt
so jetzt habe ich in mango mango mangold
salat kogler
wir haben aber es muss trotzdem und wie
schön sein weg dass mich ist das foto
schön ist alles traurig so platt war
noch drauf
das ist ein genialer bürger gemacht so 2
wenn es muss schön aussehen was ich das
sei nicht das hasen christoph sauermann
hat ist dass sarah haben kresse des
richtwertes ja das hat ja so kommt noch
ein bisschen glück salat drauf
da rot ampel dann immer noch mal ein
brötchen wahnsinn pokal kommt
unglaublich gut deutsch das ding an das
ist jetzt richtig cool und zwar das ist
unser trost haben seit elf jahren der
lega spuckt kaputt der schätzung gar
nicht mehr ausfindig der nur eine
stimmige volle power
der ist genauso wie ich immer auf
hochleistung vanessa jetzt nämlich
diesen coolen bürger und wer den posten
wie groß siehst du diesen braten sagt
sie das für euch ist das braten sagt
aber für mich hat der bürger geweint er
hat gemeinsam an
er hat geweint ja aber so war natürlich
gesehen hat hahaha ok jetzt war das ding
hier drauf jetzt drückt doch garnicht
jacke trug du verlierst du die ganze
hütte können diese haben ein anderer
anblick ist auch vielen viele viel
heißer hier am rand was ist das
interesse allerdings normal
ok jetzt das was kurz trennen lassen das
brot brot richtig saftig werden der
jetta wird sich richtig cool nußbaums
genau schluss bricht der stadt wird sich
jetzt schön um dieses hut nehmen dieses
fleisch der krumm legen und dann schön
in die poren reinkriegen und der saft
kommt raus und cbs brötchen ja ja war
man früher motivationscoach auto was auf
dem gabentisch machte daher link wird
ein charakter muri okay ich guck mal
hier eins ist es das sieht aus als hätte
er toaster die bürger gefressen wahnsinn
das ist ein richtig geniale singh böse
ist übrigens auch machen wir nicht dabei
wäre wenn monaten ja genau hätte gar
nicht die fähigkeit jetzt noch aufhalten
ja das know how jetzt holen wir den
bürger raus
oh mein gott du das ding an die gruppe
des dingern film hier mal rein siehst du
das hier ist wieder verschmolzen ist so
ein toast oder das ist ein toast so
jetzt haben wir dieses hier diesem tag
ihre messer und mit diesem nach ihrem
essen werden wir durch dieses göttliche
brot durchschneiden bürger burger brot
bürger so jetzt interessieren
achtung hörst du das hörst du das ja das
ist knusprige fleisch diese sanften
knacken zwiebeln wird diese ja so und
jetzt schaut deutlichsten an allah heißt
dass ein bürger ist dass ein bürger sind
wir nicht gut wenn wir vorne von uns
beiden schießen so ja einmal für die
presse tasting heißt auf englisch auf
deutsch probieren ihr problem ist der
macd habe ich recht du für deine mexiko
mich immer so nah ich würde mal
aggressiv und aus der spitze wie ein
schwein weil deine trost hatte ich
obwohl ich musste mich erst zum 1 1
gefallen jetzt probleme hat wie bekommen
wir beißen uns rein heißt es genial
nein gebrauchen den teller hatte
verwaltet alle sind männer wie frauen
ich kenne dich wir sind in der wildnis
wer mag probieren und zum philosophie
welt ohne krieg mensch mein gott hat
hier was mein burger gegessen
wir hatten fast einen gewissen ja aber
er die schlange
[Musik]
da kannst du kannst einen sterben gegen
sein eigenes leben alles erreichen mich
so sterben in würde sterben immer wieder
als rein das war meine letzte punkt in
meinem leben wo ich sage dass man nicht
noch einmal machen da ist ja noch ein
minister probieren ich stehe ich morgens
montagmorgens auch um 8 uhr haus ist so
breit norden gemacht
liebe zuschauer das war meine fünf
minuten
unsere big mitbürger oder auch nicht
fünf minuten oder auch nicht burger oder
auch nicht war richtig den jahren bleibt
ja nicht könnte ich mir echt ernst sein
also mir ist immer gelogen aber heute
ehrlich hammer bürger probiert diese
schritte genau
ja und schreibt mir jetzt einen
kommentare wir wirklich zeit mit uns auf
solche gefallen hat das video was ändern
können krise auch einschreibungen und
sägeholz okay ihr könnt euch auch ich
bin auch eure meinung reinschreiben auch
wenn sie uns nicht interessiert
wahrscheinlich negativ ist dass uns
ähnliches
die teilnahme ist ab
die prallen und ab und auf jeweils
macht's gut macht's besser
juni und eure moral
[Musik]
walbaum warum zumindest wolfen
ich wollte dass je länger beschäftigte
ihr könnt auch mit dem groben scheibe
eigentlich war da fällt mir kein witz
aber gerade mit sein dann geht eine mail
da muss nichts dem scooter zähler pass
auf da geht einigen die metzgerei und
sagt dann erhält 500 gramm hackfleisch
von der groben fetten dann sagt lotto
von der aktion tier sagt sagte sie mit
sorry ich heute in der schule so in
scheiben ja wie dünne oder stücke schon
dann ganz fix ist ganz fein hacken
ihr habt vielleicht muss das dann
aussehen ok also dünne scheibe warum
machen wir das
beschäftigungstherapie für die schüler
sehr fremd wird das duschen sind die
leute interessant die gewürze im mörser
zerkleinern dass die soldaten kräftig
seid ja okay und groß große starke
männer ja okay also kann man am anfang
köln
alex muss wieder zurück ich musste ich
jetzt ankündigen umgekommene klatschen
alle ja also okay lass mir jetzt bitte
kurz machen
sie bringt mich alle durcheinander okay
so